[Musik]
eine schule der achtsamkeit für kinder
und jugendliche der eindrückliche film
zeigt meint wollen es die sogenannte
achtsamkeit bewegung ist auch in der
schule angekommen
wer vor jahren meditierte wurde schräg
angeschaut
heute ist meditieren in so erlebe ich
das nur haben nicht eigentlich
meditation und meinten es religiöse
wurzeln und ist achtsamkeit heute nicht
einfach ein schmiermittel um besser zu
funktionieren um sich selbst zu
optimieren
darüber diskutiere ich mit anna gamma
sie kennen sie bereits aus dem film
anagramme ist psychologin und sein
meisterin und sie leitet in luzern ein
zentrum eben für buddhistische
meditation und für leadership
kommt ihnen das auch so vor vorjahren
meditation ja so etwas in der ecke und
heute meint fundes überall wo man
hinschaut
ja das könnte ich so bestätigen uns war
nicht nur mein fitness sondern überhaupt
meditation die das wort meditation ist
nicht mehr ein unwort oder man man muss
sich schämen oder man darf nicht darüber
reden sondern man es ist salonfähig
geworden und mein fühlen es das ist
schon eine leistung von jon kabat zinn
und der ja vor allem im
gesundheitsbereich damit unterwegs war
und jetzt entdecken dass auch andere
gesellschaftliche bereiche wie schulen
oder universitäten auch also fasst er
die renommierte universität wo ich auch
unterricht hat solche programme mit
aufgenommen weil die spüren da ist was
und ich denke mein essen das war die
leistung von ihm ist dass es säkular
daher kommt und man sich nicht so sehr
mit glaubens systemen befassen muss in
einem cappuccino zu sagen der meister
der das in die breite gebracht hat und
eben auch losgelöst eigentlich von einem
religiösen grund text
also ich habe ihn gerade unlängst an
einem kongress in einem interview
gesehen nicht mal selber zugeschaltet
aus amerika und im seinen bücher sieht
man dass weniger aber im gespräch wird
schon ganz klar woher er kommt und das
ist er ist ein buddhist und hat
techniken oder wege methoden aus der
buddhistischen tradition vor allem aus
wie passen mit aufgenommen und hat das
war genial dass wir das so übersetzen
konnte dass die leute nicht führten
überschreiten mussten sondern sich da
irgendwie einlassen konnten ohne dass
sie sich outen mussten ich bin jetzt
religiöse oder ich die höhe dieser
kirche laden oder diese religion haben
das wird das was ihr gelungen sie
erwähnen ist auch sie müssen heute
eigentlich nicht mehr sich erklären
sondern sie werden eher gefragt ja
wahrscheinlich welche art von meditation
im film sagen sie auch schulklassen sie
haben anfragen von schulklassen findet
das statt was erleben sie da wenn die
kommt daher das ist ganz faszinierend
für mich auch etwas ganz sehr schönes
weil also das sind anfragen von leder
nicht von kinder- und und dann ist es
ein teil zum beispiel dass ethik loks
denn sie da haben das ist dann in der
mittelschule und in der grundschule ist
dass religion und dann sind sie
interessiert wie ist das jetzt mit dem
buddhismus und was ist jetzt und dann
tauchen sie ein in übungen die sind dann
mehrere stunden bei uns im zentrum und
faszinierend war für mich das letzte mal
als ein jugendlicher dabei war von einem
gymnasium oder gesagt ich bin
spitzensportler wir machen genau
dieselbe übung und ja auch im
spitzensport aber sind dann ältere
jugendliche das sind jugendliche
wir haben in luzern auch ein angebot für
eltern und kinder
und es ist wunderbar wenn eltern und
kinder sich so einlassen auf achtsamkeit
übungen von wahrnehmungsübungen von
übungen der präsenz spüren die
miteinander dass da auch etwas in der
beziehung sich verändert und dass der
begegnung stattfindet auch inter stille
die zum teil sprachlos ist und
das ist für mich das miterleben darf ist
das für mich einfach glück also das sind
alle disziplin probleme sind weg die
sind ganz also wenn schulklassen kommen
ist natürlich schon so da muss man
spielen können mit den vielen nervosität
und unbekanntes und dann muss man
einfach eine klaviatur haben von
möglichkeiten wie man damit umgeht und
wenn es in der politik gibt dann steht
man auf und bewegt sich und hüpft und so
dass es dann wieder ruhiger werden kann
also sie haben spitzensport er weil ich
würd sagen eine sein meisterin sitzt
monatelang jahre lang das ist schon
spitzensport sie kommen aus einem
christlichen kontext dann jetzt eben die
den den buddhistischen hintergrund der
sei meditation aus japan
wir erleben sie das wenn jetzt überall
meint vorne ist achtsamkeit sehen sie
das thema kritisch
ja nein also ehrlich gesagt finde ich
dreimal sehr gut dass ich bin vom mein
erster beruf ist volksschullehrerin also
dass das sowas auch mit integriert wird
in die schule und gerade in der heutigen
situation wo wird auch die kinder schon
spielen mit den apparaten und und die
handys jeden überall dabei sind braucht
es auch momente wo sie zur ruhe kommen
und wo sie anleitungen bekommen wie
komme ich zur ruhe damit ich ganz da bin
damit nicht nur mein körper da ist
sondern ich mit meinem geist auch da bin
so dass ich die klausuren besser machen
kann finde ich dass etwas wunderbares
dann gibt es natürlich auch wie bei
alles kann missbraucht werden so kann
auch mein iphone als missbraucht werden
ja ich habe mich gefragt im film wird
gezeigt wie lehrerinnen lehrer dann sag
jetzt mal burnout resistenter gemacht
werden
frag ich mich einfach sollte man nicht
besser das system dann in der schule ich
bekenne mich zu wenig aus aber
limitierung der
kollektionen oder nicht noch mehr
lektionen wird man nicht besser beim
system
das ist natürlich ein thema wo ich auch
viel leidenschaft da hab' weil ich ja
eben das aus meinem ersten ruf ist und
ich bin aus zehn meisterin habe ich ja
auch schüler also frage ich mich also
bin ich ganz bei ihnen wo ich sage
natürlich muss sich das schulsystem
verändern
ich bin auch sehr unglücklich geworden
in meinem studium an einer universität
enttäuscht weil ich theologie
philosophie ja genau also weil ich
gedacht habe da lernt man wirklich zu
denken aber wenn man gute noten haben
will muss man repetieren können also
topcase machen können also dass ich
denke achtsamkeit kann auch helfen nicht
nur den lehrern sondern auch den vielen
sozusagen out of the box zu denken was
wird ein film auch erwähnt eine stimme
bei einer schülerin die sagen warum
eigentlich werden leute die tabellen
auswendig lernt belohnt und nicht denen
die verantwortung bindet oder gute
fragen stellen können und und und das
gute an jeder meditativen praxis ist
wenn sie wirklich ernsthaft geübt wird
wird man eigenständige weil es mit man
mit der zeit mehr versteht wer bin ich
und was ist die mir angelegt und so die
treue zum eigenen wesen wird dann
wesentlich und dann wird man vielleicht
auch ungemütlicher weil man nicht mehr
mit mitwirkenden scharfen mitgehen kann
sondern eben auch eigene fragen stellt
weil dann auch selber in frage gestellt
wie immer für diese art von meditation
wo es wirklich dann an die
persönlichkeit geht an die begegnung mit
sich selber dabei auch zunehmend ihr
anleiten
das ist ganz klar das ist klar als ich
meine die großen meister in ost und west
sagen der welt innenraum ist größer und
tiefer als der welt außenraum und da
gibt es schwarze löcher und da gibt es
negative materie also ich meine das ist
ne band metapher aber das gibt es auch
auf diesem weg
das sagt man auch jetzt zum beispiel im
sehen menschen die ernsthaft den weg
gehen ist es sinnvoll wenn sie sich zu
einem lehrer oder mit einem lehrer sich
begleiten lassen wobei der lehre das ist
eigentlich eine falsche bezeichnung für
mich ist er ein bergführer oder eine
bergführerin als ein lehrer weil also
eine begleitung die die gefahren auch
genug einschätzen
also mein lehrer niklaus brantschen hat
immer gesagt das ist wie wenn man auf
einen achttausender geht da ist man
besser bestellt wenn man einen
guttenberg für mitnimmt als dass man
allein probiert auf den 8000 zu kraxeln
und sich nicht auskennt so niklaus
brantschen eine suite dass ein
ordensmann der sich eben auch mit seinen
intensiv beschäftigt hat sein meister ja
wir wollen noch mal nach vorne schauen
ist ist auch diese wissenschaftliche
sicht im film angeklungen nach vorne ins
nächste gespräch dass meine kollegin
barbara bleisch führt mit richard
davidson dass ein amerikanischer
neuropsychologe und er beschäftigt sich
seit jahren sozusagen mit dieser
wissenschaftlichen seite untersuchung
meditation und er berichtet kurz von
einer begegnung mit dem dalai lama dem
dalai lama begegnete ich 1992 zum ersten
mal
damals begann unsere beziehung
inzwischen treffe ich ihn zwei drei mal
pro jahr wenige jahre nach unserer
ersten begegnung besuchte ich ihn in
seiner residenz im indischen dharamsala
da fasste er mich am arm und bat mich
auf seine direkte weise ich möchte dass
sie unsere meditationspraxis in eine
weltliche technik umwandeln und sie im
labor mit den strengsten
wissenschaftlichen methoden auf ihre
wirksamkeit hin testen wenn sie
herausfinden dass unsere art der
meditation nützlich ist verbreiten sie
sie weltweit und genau das wurde zur
aufgabe meines restlichen lebens ja
dieses vorhaben scheint ja ganz gut
geglückt zu sein
ist es denn so dass meditation er für
leute mit religiösem hintergrund meint
von s
für die atheistisch geprägten menschen
ist vielleicht würde ich da gerne vorweg
noch etwas anderes sagen ich bin der
überzeugung dass die spirituelle
intelligenz wesentlich zum menschen
gehört
okay das ein interessanter begriff
spirituelle intelligenz aber ich habe
gestern unterricht etwa
weiterbildungszentrum an der hsg st
gallen eben lieber schrieb ich hab so
genau und hab da die führungskräfte
gefragt was braucht hier um in nächste
woche in einem kritischen situation gut
erfolgreich und meisterhaft da zu sein
und wir haben dann diese qualitäten
versucht zuzuordnen zu mentalen
intelligenz und emotionale intelligenz
und so spielt wenn intelligenz und es
war in allen drei intelligenz formen
wahren qualitäten da und das ist matches
ganz sehr interessantes meinen es würde
schon meinen ist sozusagen mir eine
eintrittspforte für andere
meditationsform weil das ist mein von es
ist ein programm von acht wochen und
dann nimmt anteilig praktiziert das
selber auch der body scan die also ganz
berühmt geworden ist es tut sehr gut zur
entspannung
wer dann tennis genau das ist eine
achtsamkeit übung wo man durch den
körper spürt ohne dass man ihn bewegt
einfach nur wahrnimmt und nichts leitet
das ist sozusagen die grundübungen
dieses dieses achtwöchigen trainings
dass man jeden tag praktisch muss aber
noch auf nachfragen nicht dass mir eine
mogelpackung effektiv schauen dass
virtuellen hinter ligand sind da zum
beispiel manager management die sagen ja
ich bin konfessionsfreie ich finde die
mit dem begriff genau meine
spiritualität ist etwas was
religionsübergreifend ist in meinem
verständnis spiritualität also jetzt
wenn man das grob formuliert die
spiritualität ist der erfahrungs weg den
menschen gehen und die religiosität oder
die religion ist
verstehen die meisten menschen eher die
struktur die sich aufgebaut hat über
einen erfahrungswert also weder jesus
noch butter die haben eine struktur
überlegt wird hier oder die schulen die
es gibt in der buddhistischen tradition
ist er schon historisch die funktion
wird mit kirchen mit der institutionen
die sich darüber gebildet haben und wir
leben ja auch in einer zeit wo die
menschen sehr kritisch sind gegenüber
strukturen und institutionen und in der
postmoderne seit er unterwegs sind und
sagen ich gehe meinen weg und ich gucke
mir das an und tut mir das gut und wenn
nicht dann gehe ich weiter und wobei es
immer noch menschen gibt die sehe in
dieser struktur beheimatet sind
aber es gibt immer mehr menschen die ich
sagen das kann ich auch nicht sein also
wo es auch ein clash gibt von von werten
gehende strukturen lebendig sind wenn es
eine hierarchischen struktur ist wie man
es nicht nur in der im christentum kennt
sondern ich kenne das auch in der
buddhistischen tradition das war für
mich eine einfache zu sehen dass es dort
nicht ganz nicht anders ist wie bei uns
und dann im business bereich wurden in
der arbeit müssen sie kreativ unterwegs
sein das gibt ein clash und wie geht man
mit diesen gleich oben und dann gibt es
leute die ist sehr spirituell sind die
sagen aber ich finde da keine struktur
ich kann kann mich nicht eine
gruppierung so ordnen oder ich kann da
nicht ja und amen sagen während ich im
alltag wo ich die meisten stunde meines
tages verbringe haben wir's
herausgefordert bin also sie wehren sich
merklich gegen diese separierung das ist
mit religion für die einen das ist ohne
mit anderen da haben sie ganz anderen
begriff von spiritualität
ich habe sehr weil sie sind christlich
katholisch sozialisiert sie haben einen
langen weg gemacht bis zu zehn meisterin
also buddhistische sein meditation
können sie mal kurz sagen wenn wir mal
sagen ganz grob christliche meditation
was ist da das ziel
buddhistische meditation also jetzt
konkret sein meditation und meint füllen
ist können wir das mal so ein bisschen
auseinander nehmen also im christentum
gibt es ja verschiedene formen des
gebetes also wenn wenn wie ich möchte
das jetzt reduzieren und und sagen es
gibt die christliche kontemplation was
sagt man und die referenzen sind dann
meister eckhart teresa von ávila und da
gibt es ganz texte die ganz nah sind der
praxis die man auch findet in mein
fernes yoga oder ok so ist beispiel aus
der sogenannten mystik gewählt haben wir
also die innere gottesbegegnung haben
die wirklich die menschen in seinem
inneren stadt findet das leuchtet mir
ein dass ich wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
ein randständiger war
der schreibt zum beispiel ich sitzen ich
will schweigend ich will hören was gott
ihn mir reden
aber dann gibt es auch einen text er
sagt wie wunderbar draußen stehen wie
drinnen
und das finde ich das faszinierende also
wenn ich jetzt mit ihnen spreche dass
ich mir gleichzeitig zuhören und
verbunden bleibe mit meinem meine
inneren kosmos also dass ich mich weder
im außen vor niere oder auch im innen
verliere
und diese botschaft die finde ich auch
in der zentralregion genau aber die
meditation dort ist doch zentriert auf
zum beispiel wahrnehmung des atems das
ist wie passen und das ist die meint
filmes aus achtsamkeit praxis im sehen
das ist auch eine form der achtsamkeit
praxis aber die ist so rudimentär so
einfach nur atmen nichts ausatmen und
nicht mal den atem beobachten sondern es
das ziel ist eigentlich eins zu werden
mit dem atem ganz arm zu sein
einatmen ausatmen und es ist ebenso der
arten der bringt das ist ja eigentlich
das ziel aller meditativen praktiken
dass man ankommt im hier und jetzt im
körper sind wir
da wo wir sind mit unserem geist sieht
wir vielleicht dort und da und tier und
so und für mich eben die achtsamkeit
deshalb finde ich dass ich finde das
wunderbar dass es das gibt weil sie so
ziemlich alltagstauglich ist ich denke
viele menschen kennen die situation man
kann stressig von der arbeit nach hause
und dann sitzt man gegenüber und dann
sagt vielleicht die person die mir
gegenübersitzt h wo bist du bist du
überhaupt da und ich denke das größte
geschenk das wir uns gegenseitig machen
können ist dass wir da sind wo wir sind
also die berühmte frage duschen sie wenn
sie duschen
das ist ja eine gelegenheit wo man den
gedanken schon den ganzen tag durch
rattert aber eigentlich sind wir
momentan darf ich noch die differenz
doch etwas betonen ich habe selber zum
beispiel die sogenannten exerzitien
kennengelernt geld gemacht bei sie haben
etwas branchenevent bei jesuiten wird
man auch von frauen begleitet wo man
aber wirklich unter anleitung dann auch
mit biblischen texten also ich würd
sagen wirklich auf einem religiösen weg
ich sage es jetzt ganz vereinfacht doch
begegnung mit sich selber und
gottesbegegnung unterwegs ist kennt und
das ist doch etwas ganz anderes als
diese meditation ja also ich mein es
gibt in der meditation rechnet man mit
fünf formen und erste formen kommt dem
der achtsamkeit plawky sehr nah ich habe
auch somit sein angefangen wo ich
nämlich eine eine technik gesucht habe
die mich relativ schnell runter fährt
von so und dann habe ich diese form
kennen gelernt und habe gemerkt die
entspricht irgendwo meinen wesen und das
nennt man im fachausdruck nennt man das
bomben
das ist einfach wohlfühl senden und es
gibt leute die bleiben dort stehen und
dann gibt es die andere form die heißt
an gevo sein wo man die die technik
beibehält die entwickelt worden ist in
china und in japan aber
dann mit anderen religiösen system
verbindet ja und das ist dann das game
center sie ist dann das christlich ist
der punkt ist auch in der christlichen
kontemplation spricht man es ist besser
zu sitzen als zu stehen das heißt im
osten ist dieses eigentlich eben mit
methodisch aufgearbeitet worden wie man
am schnellsten am besten zur ruhe kommt
aber man findet elemente auch im
christentum und was jetzt ansprechen ich
habe auch ignazio mische exerzitien
besucht ich das wort gebet also das
automatische vaterunser beten das ist
das kann ja auch fast wie ein mantra
sein und dann ist das nächste ist dass
man es verbindet mit den zähnen mit
inhalten dann die japanische nec setzen
wo man dann ganz eintaucht in die
geschichte die mir dann gegen kommt dass
man die begegnung geht sich visualisiert
das kennen sie alles auch und das ziel
ist eigentlich bei allen dass das
gleiche was ich unterrichte in meinem
zentrum nutzer saßen in der
buddhistischen tradition in österreich
unter richtig sein und christliche
mystik und ich mische nicht
und das finde ich das absolute
interessante aber das ist zum beispiel
kommen auch leute die religiös sind ja
klar
klar und wird das faszinierende ist je
mehr ich das wort buddha in den mund
nehmen kommen die leute und sagen ich
glaube ich muss mich auseinandersetzen
das ist einen eigentlichen christus los
und wie ist das mit jesus und und das
ist eigentlich auch eine gesetzmäßigkeit
wenn wir offen genug sind und dem
fremden zu begegnen werden wir
herausgefordert zu verstehen was ist
denn jetzt eigentlich mit mir
ich verstehe schon sie betonen mehr das
was zusammen führt was zusammenhält was
sagen sie leuten die sagen ja das ist
winkler dies muss da wird alles zusammen
gemischt und dann am schluss haben wir
müssen also ich bin eben
ich bin nicht fan vom synkretismus eben
das hab ich ja gesagt ich liebe dich die
spannung also dass ich neben österreich
gehörten die kein wort von buddha ohne
e10
kein wort von christus und emir diese
spannung auszuhalten
das hat mich über jahre sehr beschäftigt
ich bin auch öfters gereist und habe mir
wenn ich da wird über den himalaya
geflogen habe ich immer gedacht ja was
wäre mit mir gewesen wenn ich da in
tibet geboren wäre oder über den hof
geflogen bin was werde ich wenn ich da
in einem dort einen urwald aufgewachsen
wäre ich sicher nicht katholisch oder
großer wahrscheinlichkeit nicht und ein
zen meister auf hawaii
der hat mir eine antwort gegeben seither
frage ich nicht mehr sagt die wurzeln
aller religionen ist dasselbe und das
team ist auch dass sie wieder in die
einheit zu kommen
die verbundenheit mit dem urgrund allen
seins und es ist kein fehler dass sich
verschiedene religionen entwickelt haben
und dann sagt er noch als ich ihm gesagt
habe ich also ich mein und dann begegne
ich auch dem schamanismus in wenn man in
bestimmte kulturen ein taucht dann kommt
das einen entgegen auch wenn die leute
sehr intellektuell auch unterwegs sind
dann sagt er wir tragen die samen aller
religionen in uns und diejenigen die wie
wir wissen
dazu gehören und heute gibt es immer
mehr menschen die sagen ich habe eine
doppelte zugehörigkeit das sage ich auch
ich habe eine doppelte zugehörigkeit
oder eine dreifache oder sogar ich bin
transfers und sie sagen das kann man das
interesse auch wecken die eigene oder
die ursprüngliche tradition besser
kennenzulernen und der punkt ist einfach
auch wenn man meditiert dann bekommt man
ein neues verständnis
oben nicht mehr für wahr halten was
andere mir sagen das ist wahr sondern es
geht über die eigene erfahrung eine
verinnerlichung was sagen sie zu dem
vorwurf jahr hat die leute meditierender
und verabschieden sich ein stück weit
von der welt dass gibt es das gibt es
auch im selben es gibt die wohl
berühmteste geschichte im selben haus
der ochse unter hirte und das sind 10
bilder und es gibt eine schule da hört
man beim achter ochsen bild auf und da
ist es ist man in der lehre und
unendlichkeit es in der metapher im
himmel und kümmert sich nicht mehr um
die welt und das ist der china jana
buddhismus dann gibt es aber eine andere
schule gesagt nein es endet ich dort und
ich man kann den leuten das ansehen ob
sie jetzt einfach nur ich für mich für
mein wohlbefinden also nicht nur für
sich was ich gesagt habe was bei mir am
anfang stand sondern dass man irgendwann
mal wenn wir wirklich ernsthaft den weg
geht in einem bewusstseins raum auch
eintaucht
er ist absolute plus
und dann gibt es leute die durch stehen
sein
ich habe mal mit einem park gearbeitet
da kam sie uns hat gesagt es schon gut
dass er meditiert er ist ein besserer
mann geworden aber kommt am abend nach
hause ich habe das nach dessen der
serviert und ganz verabschiedet der sich
anderthalb stunden auf seinen kasten
aber dass das gibt es aber dass ich bin
nicht fan davon sieben wo stehen sie
heute daher also ich wenn der weg ist
erst zu ende wenn wir auf dem marktplatz
zurückgeben des lebens und mein ziel
auch in meinen trainings und lehrgängen
ist dass es dass wir den menschen das
becken bzw dass sie realisieren da ist
eine instanz in uns wo wir ganz ruhig
sein können auch inmitten des hurrikans
sondern das ist dass die menschen sich
einmischen engagieren hinstehen was in
der heutigen zeit für mich absolut ein
muss ist so sage ich manchmal sage ich
in meinen zähnen
wochen das ist politisches training hier
das dass ihr wirklich tief verwurzelt in
sein damit ihr nicht umkippt wenn es
stimmt sondern dass ihr das rückgrat
stützt und und es auch nicht steif wird
sondern lebendig wie ein bambus bewegen
könnt aber dass er nicht davon rennt und
dass ihr da bleibt und vielleicht noch
ein punkt in diesen wir haben ja diesen
film gesehen dass wir nicht sehr
spannend wird's ja die frage ist was
macht uns mitmenschliche welche
meditationspraxis da gibt es ja eben
auch spannen die untersuchung mal aus
der hirnforschung
es ist nicht sehen sondern das ist
liebende güte meditation dass man
spricht sich selber zuspricht möglich
wirklich sein mögen sie glücklich sein
das öffnet vielmehr den beziehungs
aspekt und hilft mitfühlender da zu sein
dann wollen wir doch mit diesem wunsch
schließen anagramme herzlichen dank für
diesen einblick in diese vielfalt eben
der formen der praktiken von meditation
achtsamkeit meinten es herzlichen dank
dann kinder für das gespräch und hier
geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit dem
thema meint von svb bleistift einen
crack der meint von es zähne und einen
kritiker sie will wissen ob sich das
verhalten von menschen durch achtsamkeit
und meditation wirklich beeinflussen
lässt
[Musik]
hallo